I want to ask you an individual question
that actually doesn't have to do with
this movie like the entire planet I
absolutely adore and love the Paddington
movies I think they're masterpieces both
of them and I know that there's a third
one being made so what can you tell
people about it
really very little because I haven't
read this script
and I don't even know when we're due to
shoot it or
well
I I don't know I thought it would be
happening by now but I don't know maybe
there's it's gone it's gone silent in
the way that sometimes these things do
maybe that's
just means they're still working on it
or maybe it means it's not happening or
you just don't know I wonder if it's
because Paul is involved in um the Wonka
movie
yeah it might be but well no it wouldn't
be because Paul is not sadly anything to
do with well I wonder if he's like
producing or writing or he might he
might not have some involvement on that
level yeah but he's definitely not
directing this one yeah and I have to
just if you don't mind like do you do
you realize how many people though those
movies are amazing like are you aware of
that have you paid attention
yeah I I I I love them too and I see
that they really
affect people and um
yeah I do I love that
um I I'm very happy that it's
so
um so close to people's hearts it's
great I think yeah I'm not sure if
you've seen them
yeah there it is there it is okay ready
oh dear right I thought you guys were
friends what happened you went to the
premiere you haven't seen them
if you haven't seen the single one of
them right here's the microphone because
I'd like to make sure we get it on
record not a single one
no
your your reaction is nice says it all I
have no official comment
I do remember you coming home from ADR a
whole day of ADR the way you had just
been making
um Paddington Bear
um grow growling noises some days I just
go in and do like about 30 or 40
different growls
yeah
it's like the whole day
you get the list of things you have to
do and you guys tiny growl
it's more very growl small disappointed
growl
all right well
no more Sunday
[Music]
S I do actually hear it's great I'll
produce who was saying she watched it
the other day a moment of deep stress
and it made everything better they are
they're delightful